cuz when the way I'm going to take care
of this integrate here is i'm i remember
my double angle formulas right just put
this off on the side here close to theta
that's cos squared minus sine squared so
I want you to remember that I can get
rid of one of these side skirts because
these are the Pythagorean identity these
are interchangeable right so this is
actually con sweared by this 1 minus cos
square right that's why the substitute
for sine squared there so looking for
the double maybe of there this is what
I'm getting
ok now what I want is to substitute a
cos squared which I have to sum close to
theta business so all I need to do is to
add 1 to both sides see you can see I
could add 1
like that and then all I need to do now
animate clothes wet the subject so I can
keep my substitution is 2/2
okay so so this is the result I want so
therefore my Ichigo I'm not continuing
over there is 9 times 1 plus cos 2 theta
or 2 with respect to theta or we change
the variable addition law we go and our
minds will take a factor of 1/2 out
now I'm going to go ahead and I'm going
to actually integrate now because I can
really do this this is a former ranking
minute so I've got my nine hours to out
the front one when I integrated become
Xanthia cos 2 theta is going to because
his reverse chain rule so this looks
like it's going to be a half a side deal
plus cost occurs in definitely mentally
check if my differentiate is when I get
back to cos 2theta the to come out the
front kids with half side becomes cosine
okay now this is excellent but that it's
some integrated but it's not answering
the question because the original
question had nothing to do with you know
I introduced theta to help me go through
the actual process of integration to do
with the calculus bids but now that I've
done that I've got to get back to X's
okay so how am I gonna do that you've
got to return to your original
substitution this day and we're gonna
have to do two things with him to
completely retreads like this back into
X's the first place these have the area
of fear
well today theater the subject here to
rearrange a little bit and I'm gonna
have to use my unique knowledge of
inverse tree I could say sine of theta
is equal to x3 so therefore even the
right domain and we'll talk about this
in future examples in more detail
because it is important in the right
domain I can take sine inverse of both
sides and I get this guy okay so that's
nice I'll be able to take care of theta
there by substituting for that but how
do I deal with this this is a bit icky
right my original function is in terms
of a single theta not in terms of two
theta and what you know it's not just as
simple as well I'm going to put two
there I can put two there we know from
what I work with three that don't work
or formulas compatible form is not that
simple
okay so here's what I'm going to do
before I go ahead and start trickling
all this back into Exodus I'm gonna say
look
if I look at this guy I want to get back
from double eagles into singles well I'm
just gonna use the double angle formula
for mystery the dominant formula for
sine is to sign me up close better
now maybe I see some progress this is
already better than what I had before
because well I mean kids on these are
consistent but look Sophia I know it's
only is it's an excellent thing I can
take care of that
but what's cos theta we're gonna do with
the closed video now I already have
something written for cos theta on the
wall but I could such as you it's this
like here if I divide by 3 I could use
that but this is not going to help me
right because what am I trying to do I
am trying to get rid of theaters replace
them with X's if I substituted this year
which is the excellent defeat on a pre
another theater it for the 119 yeah this
is no help at all so to stand what I
need to do is I need to a people to a
triangle I have to say look if X is
equal to sine beta or site there is X
1/3 I can draw a triangle its remaining
good and again you gotta be careful with
I'm a nutritionist I'll talk about that
in future example I can draw a triangle
which has to Peter in it if sine theta
is X book three that opposite of what
you see you can use Pythagoras II to
work out the missing side is done
square root of L minus X square so
therefore if I'm looking at cycle you
know I know what that is if I'm gonna
get cos theta is adjacent over
hypotenuse that's 1 cos theta so I can
substitute that in by saying in this
triangle cos theta is equal to this
okay so now I'm ready now I have all of
the pieces I can say all of my feeders I
go to become X's in the center right
I've got my 9 how to you at the front
I already know that fear is signing this
off etc so you can see one of the
reasons why even though the substitution
I did to actually integrate this it's
just a regular tree one but where it
leads you is industry because you're
going to undo that substitution it's
that's why we're down to the other side
there are you know that's that's up
until three so that new thing and they
could see it which I just determined is
he our tsubasa planet you like that that
is the square root of nine minus x
squared
we're basically done it's all a little
bit to tidy up which is that you can see
this is a bit of a kind of amorphous if
what I do is on visit as a factor if not
and down the bottom you can see on
cancel
so if I put that nine inside the bracket
9 sine inverse of X on 3 this side and
this side cancel which leaves me with X
9 1 is x squared and don't forget your
constant okay
exhale okay now there's a lot of whack
and there were lots of liver traps in
weed these in there
it's worth looking to say this is a weed
result right we're expecting something
Zippo related to a semi-circle why is it
such a a royal mess okay well I want you
to return to the original problem which
is the city center
let me draw people in for you what has
this naira
allow us to do okay what we now see is
if we have a center
so now that I've done all of this
calculus right if I want to integrate
over any particular interval I now have
the machinery to do it right I could say
go from any any way to evaluate I like
not just convenient ones like they gives
you three was zero to three I've been
saying go from misty three
I could for instance go from one to two
okay what is this area
now just consider if we didn't know
calculus how would you go about finding
this area because surely it's possible
right when you think about it what kind
of shape is it similar to it looks a lot
like a trapezium with a curvy bit on
there what's different between it and
the answer it is the difference is this
pie here and that's a segment so I could
work out the area of that trapezium how
I do that I need to know
miss leaf how that do that I'm gonna
need some bangles in here and I'm going
to I could substitute it like this this
is the square root of the square root of
nine minus x squared so it X equal 1
this value up here will be the square
root of 8 so that's that leg and when I
sequel to you're gonna get no - for sure
over here
this is the square root of five you can
see this time you get a key right these
square roots away these are P yeah how
am I gonna work out that kind of man
well so I got the segment I'm going to
have to do something like this right I'm
gonna have to work out what this angle
is in here then I can work out the area
of the center take away the area
triangle and then give me that small
green sliver and doing that is going to
happen to invoke this guy right so you
can see even though this looks messy the
messiness of this careful calculus
Accords exactly with the messages of the
geometry if you try to do it now in
calculus okay so in summary all that
practice that we did with integration by
substitution and working out how to
change the variable and so on
it sort of unlocks all of these problems
with a much more challenging okay as I
mentioned as extension one students was
very commonly be given the suggested
substitution exception to students
they're going to be expected to kind of
identify that yourself from greater
familiarity with run into
okay